[Musique]
e
des parcs pour enfants comme celui ci il
y en a 26 sur la côte est des états unis
ils sont dédiés à chacune des 26
victimes qui ont été abattus à l'école
sandy hook de newton au connecticut
c'était le 14 décembre 2012 celui ci
porte le nom de jesse lewis un élève de
6 ans assassiné tout comme dix neuf
autres enfants et six adultes
c'est à peu près tout ce qu'il reste de
cette horrible tragédie
[Musique]
à
car après avoir enterré ses 26 morts
nota nanterre et sa honte
ne cherchez pas la maison où habitait le
tueur elle était démolie
tout comme l'école où a eu lieu la
fusillade et les été rasés puis
reconstruite comme si rien de tout cela
n'était arrivé il ya cinq ans c'est
d'ailleurs ce que veulent nous faire
croire les conspirationnistes
aujourd'hui encore pour eux la fusillade
n'était qu'un complot fomenté par ceux
qui voulaient renforcer le contrôle des
armes à feu
les parents des acteurs payer les
enfants
certains même n'aurait jamais existé la
tuerie une mise en scène
c'est presque un déni de la société
américaine face au débat sur les armes à
feu depuis newton
rien n'a vraiment changé en fait pas
tout à fait par exemple plus d'une
vingtaine d'états ont adouci leur propre
loi pour étendre le droit de port
d'armes dans les écoles les aéroports et
les églises neowin net star et the good
guys
une poignée d'autres états ont renforcé
la vérification des antécédents pour
ceux qui veulent acheter des armes à feu
ou même on bannit la vente des armes
d'assaut
mais rien n'empêche un citoyen d'aller
dans un état voisin pour acheter tout ce
qu'il veut en vente libre depuis newton
le congrès à rejeter plus d'une centaine
de projets de loi sur le contrôle des
armes à feu et après chaque tragédie
c'est toujours la même chose au grand
plaisir du lobby des armes à feu la
fameuse un arrêt qui depuis les 20
dernières années a dépensé plus de 200
millions de dollars pour se faire
entendre auprès des politiciens
résultat depuis newton il ya maintenant
cinq ans il y a eu plus de 1500
fusillade meurtrière aux états unis qui
ont fait plus de 1800 morts et plus de
6000 blessés
[Musique]
e
orlando las vegas virginia tech sur
dheune springs au texas autant de
fusillades qui ont littéralement écrasé
le nombre record de morts lors de la
tuerie de columbine en 1999 une tuerie
qui avait pourtant marqué les américains
mais dans un pays où il ya presque
autant d'armes que deux citoyens
il n'y a pas grand monde pour faire
bouger les choses les parents des
victimes de l'école sainte des eaux qui
s'accroche à un seul et dernier espoir
celui d'obtenir le droit de poursuivre
les manufacturiers d'armes à feu qui
seul heureux font la promotion des
mesures et de leurs produits mais ce ne
sera pas facile car depuis 2005
washington a accordé en grande partie
une immunité à tous les fabricants
d'armes à feu lorsque leurs produits
sont impliqués dans des crimes incombe a
donc presque perdu d'avancé
mais un combat nécessaire selon les
parents qui ne veulent pas que leurs
enfants soient morts assassinés pour
rien
[Musique]